Shawna's with us in Medford Oregon hey
Shawna how are you wonderful thank you
for taking my call from our situation
we've been doing your program for three
years we paid off ninety thousand in
debt and have cash flows another sixty
thousand because of course Murphy hit us
with every possible home repair well and
our situation now is that we only have
our house and our student loans left my
husband is an optometrist and our
student loans are about 350 I know I
know
our house is at 170 so our question is
we love our house like the location is
great it's not even it's by the school
by our church a mile from his work like
we just love it but it is also we owe
170 and the values gone up to about 390
so we question like should we sell our
house to pay off part of our student
loans but then still have to move
somewhere and have some sort of housing
and attack the rest of the student loans
or what should we do
that'd be my worst-case scenario what's
your household income his pay is 110 but
with bonuses he's been averaging about
like 140 over the last two years Wow do
you see that what what kind of a
trajectory is that on you know are we
seeing 202 years or what no he is great
and wonderful and every year he's made
more and more and every year he says
well I won't make that much next year
but he keeps making more every year so
I'm not sure if you asked him he would
say we're not like we're not going to
make as much as we did the year before
but he has grown every year by about
20,000 that makes me want to smack him
and say why did you go through and
$50,000 in debt to go make less every
year and start at 140 they tell you it's
not a big deal
yeah I know
but they're idiots and so now you're in
a mess and so you know he also be making
200 a year okay to get your way out of
this so I need him I need him to kick
his ambition level up about three
notches here okay and no I wouldn't sell
your house but I would Jack him up okay
lots of optometrist made quarter million
we work with them all the time we were
it's not that unusual they build a
practice over time it's not
instantaneous coming out of school they
don't make that but he can build a
practice and and that includes the sale
of the eyewear and the sale of the
contacts and there's margin out your
ears and that stuff and so I'm receiving
into that myself but the anyway the it
can be done and I don't know what type
of practice he's in if he's working for
a company or what he's doing but I would
begin to you know let's let's further
his career and get your numbers up and
keep your house is what I would say Ken
you got an insight yeah I I'm blind as a
bat without these contacts and you're
right there's so much margin in
optometry and he's got to grow the
business he's got to be looking how do I
grow the business and then with the
surplus of the growth of the business
he's not paying himself anymore he's
paying this debt down it's very doable
you're absolutely right it's it would be
crazy for somebody else but he can grow
that business I mean if you can get the
200 and you live on 75 if you keep the 7
175 house right right note and then you
start throwing 100 a year at this and
how quickly just 350 go away at 100 a
year going towards it three and a half
years that starts to make sense
140 I'm throwing 50 at it now I got an
eight year plan and that's very
difficult I'm very concerned that an
optometrist feels he's capped like ready
you and I don't believe in that it's
capitalism he can bring in more
customers by the way it's they may not
you may not own the practice and this
guy that was working for LensCrafters or
something you know so that that's
flexible but but you know the point is
you're not stuck there you you know you
you got medical school debt you've got a
medical degree so let's use it and turn
it into something instead of that that's
the ambition thing and figuring out how
to do that and a different way to
monetize your
licensed your skillset into the
marketplace that's what you're looking
for I would do that rather than sell the
house if you're gonna be making one
40-odd infinitum and that's the
projection for the next seven years sell
the house but I wouldn't accept that
answer if I were in your shoes I would
always go okay I went to all this
trouble I ain't go to all this trouble
make 140 okay I think and go to all this
trouble to make that kind of money and
and be worried that I'm going backward
every year that's not what we're gonna
do so you know sometimes can with what
you do on the King Coleman show is that
kind of a call where it's just someone
that doesn't believe and you just need
to speak it into them huh it's a
limiting belief that I don't have any
options I'm completely stuck and when
you're stuck you're not really stuck
you're just looking at your
circumstances but you start looking up
and you find a way out absolutely